[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts the role of defense
against the dark arts professor
and none other than gilderoy lockhart
defense against the dark arts was
perhaps
one of the most important parts of the
curriculum at hogwarts
a course that focused on teaching
students how to defend themselves
against aspects
of the dark arts during the time the
trio attend hogwarts voldemort and his
followers were very much on the rise
some doubted it fudge but others knew
that it was inevitable
unfortunately one of the people who knew
it was going to happen
was dumbledore a resurgence of voldemort
and the death eaters
meant a resurgence of dark magic and so
it made sense that students would need
to be able to properly defend themselves
against such magic avada cadaver crucio
imperio the students needed to know
about these spells
so that they could defend themselves at
a certain point understanding these
spells
became a matter of life or death but
this just makes the question
even more potent why on earth was
gilderoy lockhart
ever hired let's take a look at the man
that became the 92-93 school year's
defense against the dark arts professor
gilda roy lockhart was a british
half-blood wizard
born in the year 1964 to a witch mother
and muggle father
his parents had two other children two
girls but
lockhart proved to be the only one that
was magical
which whether she would admit it or not
made him his mother's favorite child
lockhart was a clever good-looking boy
and when he realized quite early on that
he was magical
it only went to his head and inflated
his already massive ego
even further in 1975 lockhart began
attending hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry four years
after notable characters
like severus snape sirius black and
james potter
to name a few when lockhart first walked
through the door to the school
he was met with disappointment as he
came to the crushing realization
that at a school for witches and wizards
he was just another magical young boy
in the muggle world gilderoy was
exceptional but here he didn't stand out
and that's all he ever longed for it's
been expressed that
as a young boy lockhart did possess
slightly above average abilities
but nothing particularly noteworthy and
his lack of attention
only fueled the fire inside of him to be
successful
lockhart was eventually sorted into
ravenclaw house which is not entirely
befitting of him in my opinion
and narrowly avoided being sorted into
slytherin
even in school lockhart loved to brag
and inflate his own ego
even going as far as to blatantly lie if
it meant that it would positively change
someone's perception of him
it was ingrained in him since childhood
he wanted to be great
he wanted to be the man the people
talked about in legends
in 1982 lockhart finally graduated from
hogwarts
and it was at this point in time that he
began traveling all around the world
shortly after graduating lockhart began
to build prominence as an author
telling his readers tales of heroism and
illustrious magical ability
he was a dark wizard catcher a dragon
tamer a troll conqueror
if there was a dark and powerful
presence in the world lockhart had
vanquished it all by himself
the catch only he was there to witness
it after each and every time that
lockhart traveled
he would return home with a new book
filled with self-promotion
heroism and extravagance and it really
left a positive impression on the
magical population
he began to receive genuine praise for
what he was doing he received an order
of merlin
third class a very prestigious award and
was even invited to join the ministry of
magic's
dark force defense league lockhart's old
professors at hogwarts
even began to question whether they had
misjudged the confusing young boy
while he attended the school he told
book signings all over the magical world
and people loved to be near lockhart it
was everything that he had ever dreamt
of
however there was actually quite a
sinister side to lockhart that i feel
wasn't addressed to the extent that it
should have been
in the books and films you see lockhart
was a memory charm
master and this was one of the reasons
that he had been able to falsify
his well existence lockhart actually
wasn't a troll conqueror or dragon tamer
he was a phony and all he did when he
traveled around the world
was hear the stories of genuinely
accomplished wizards wipe their memories
then claim the accomplishment as his own
though lockhart is eventually found out
and stripped of his titles
i don't think that the severity of
wiping people's memories
without their consent was ever properly
addressed to the extent that it should
have been
however lockhart paid his dues when his
own memory charm backfired on him
effectively erasing all of his memories
and causing him to become a permanent
resident
of saint mongo's hospital so this man
this phony
how could he have ever become a
professor at hogwarts surely dumbledore
must have been able to see
right through him right part of the
reason that lockhart ended up with the
position
was the fact the defense against the
dark arts role was cursed
the role was subject to much instability
and no one seemed to be able to keep the
role
for more than a year dumbledore explains
this you see
we have not been able to keep a defense
against the dark arts professor
for more than a year since i refused the
post to lord voldemort
you see voldemort was spiteful because
he had been denied the role on numerous
occasions
when a young tom riddle first graduated
from the school he asked
then headmaster armando dippet for the
position
however given that riddle was only 18
years old the time
dippett cordially rejected riddle but
did encourage him to apply again
in a few years fast forward a bit later
riddle did reapply to the school
and at this point in time dumbledore was
the headmaster
however dumbledore knew of riddle's dark
side and likely felt that no good would
come from his placement
for that reason rill's application was
denied once more
furious with the fact that he had been
denied a placement at the school on two
occasions
riddle cursed the role and ever since
that day no professor seems to have been
able to stay in a position
for more than one year when harry first
starts at hogwarts
quirrell holds the position but as we
know that didn't last
and when he shows up in second year he's
met with none other than gilderoy
lockhart
we'll let him introduce himself me
gilderoy lockhart
order of merlin third class honorary
member of the dark force defense league
and five-time winner of the witch
weekly's most charming smile award
but i don't talk about that i didn't get
rid of the band and banshee by smiling
at her
after lockhart was hired many of the
staff were baffled with the decision
that dumbledore had made
many of them taught lockhart first hand
and knew of his ostentatious tendencies
entirely unimpressed by the chronicles
of heroism that he had since published
however it's later revealed that
dumbledore strategically hired lockhart
for a number of reasons you see
dumbledore knew that lockhart was a
fraud
or at least suspected it and the
following excerpt from pottermore
supports this
albus dumbledore's plans however ran
deep he happened to have known two of
the wizards
for whose life's work gilderoy lockhart
had taken credit
and was one of the only people in the
world who thought he knew what lockhart
was up to
as we can see dumbledore personally knew
two people that lockhart had stolen
potential fame and
valor from and so he must have known
that lockhart's stories were falsified
because he knew the actual witches and
wizards that had accomplished these
feats
damodal wanted to expose lockhart for
what he had done but he wanted it to
come out naturally
he wanted to put lockhart in a
vulnerable position so that he would
effectively expose himself
you see talented wizard though he was
lockhart had spent so many years
perfecting memory charms
that his ability in other aspects of
magic was very unimpressive
dumbledore was convinced that lockhart
needed only to be put back into an
ordinary school setting
to be revealed as a charlatan and a
fraud professor mcgonagall who had never
liked
lockhart asked dumbledore what he
thought students would learn
from such a vain fame-hungry man
dumbledore replied that
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be ah
dumbledore
so wise so dumbledore wanted him there
for a couple of reasons
the first reason being that hogwarts was
the perfect environment
to expose a fraud that had capitalized
on the lives of others
and the second reason was simply that
hogwarts needed a defense against the
dark arts professor
and no one was applying rumors had began
circulating about the curse on a
position
and no one wanted to take it nomurdor
knew however
that if he was able to leverage harry
potter he could get lockhart to accept
the role
lockhart might not have been keen to
return to hogwarts given how well his
career of stolen glory was progressing
had dumbledore not dangled the promise
of harry potter over his fame hungry
head
by subtly suggesting that teaching harry
potter would set the seal on lockhart's
fame
dumbledore had set a lure that lockhart
could not resist
so as we can see the placement of
lockhart at hogwarts was
always fully intentional dumbledore
wasn't caught up in the hype of
lockhart's name or
endeavors he knew what he was all along
but brought him to hogwarts
so that he could set an example for the
students in dumbledore's own words
an incompetent professor was a good
lesson in and of itself
of what not to do and how not to be
and that's it for this video why did you
guys think lockhart was hired
did you always know that dumbledore did
it strategically or did you think that
it was just a glimmer of incompetence
shining through in dumbledore's
character let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry